how far away from you he was was he
maybe two feet away from me who feet
away but there was like an office
partition like about this high you know
and then a desk on this side so he was
on the other side of the partition to
make the cubicles so I was under the
desk
breathing heavy so scared and just
thinking I hope he doesn't hear me I'm
trying not to breathe you know because I
didn't wanted to hear me and I guess he
didn't hear me but Gerald and Rob were
on the other side of the runway
partition thing and I heard you know
shouting screaming stuff and then I
heard you know more shots and they got
shot and I think I might have heard some
groaning for a little bit and then I'm
like oh he's gonna come because now he
cleared that side of the room now he's
gonna turn around and come around and
look and see I mean if anybody was hide
and I thought and I had a there was an
office chair kind of in front of me and
I said if I see his legs I'm gonna push
this chair out as hard as I can to try
to knock him off his balance and I'd you
know try to get him but he didn't come
towards me he started heading back
towards where the reporters are which is
farther down the runway in the office
like in the back where the reporter pen
is and the sports area sports writers
are usually at I didn't know who was
back there you know or anything but he
had been shooting on and off you know
shooting the different people all around
me